hey kids embryonic stem cell research is
fun now you all know about Obama ending
the ban of the harvesting of embryos for
stem cell research calling it an
important step and the advancing the
cause of science in America the truth
though is that virtually all medical
progress has been made with adult stem
cell research there are over 70 diseases
being treated through current stem cell
programs
none of them through embryonic even the
market reflects that matter of fact so
little promise has been shown with
embryonic stem cell research that
venture capitalists have never really
shown an interest in investing yet this
administration still wants to fund it
with more of your tax dollars the
federal government why are you guys so
hell-bent on pushing this lemon of a
product you're like a bad used-car
salesman with a liquidation sale going
on fight folks thanks your old friend
crazy freak from crazy freight divorcing
bark hey I got a deal for you thanks to
a sudden influx of federal funding I'm
overstocked with embryos and I'm so
crazy about low prices I'm practically
giving them away so come on down the
crazy Precambrian expensive and Boreum
we've got embryos of all shapes and
sizes and at this price you can afford
to buy ríos are all the rage in
washington DC so don't play lick the
hand on the trick crazy Pete isn't the
only one everybody's going crazy for
embryonic stem sale just listen to these
testimonials I was so amazed how well
crazy piece embryos work I ended up
buying them in bulk
crazy Pete's embryonic stem cells are
amazing I can't believe how well these
stem cells work they're fantastic
their smile if you have an injury organ
for body parts of age Nixon just booked
the every on extending sales in the job
and let their Halen action don't work
Wow
don't listen all those conservative
fools who will tell you that embryonic
stem cells having so much promise
they're probably [ __ ] decide there
are plenty of uses for these little
critters every onyx denzel's are cute
they're cuddly and their kids love them
beside rock so what are you waiting for
go crazy treat now for your embryonic
stem cells and eliminate off the price
of 1995 it's a stale once more that's
crazy preach every onyx 10 sale Emporium
crazy preach every on extending sale
Emporium harvested every hosing slashing
gratis will throw in a free Vermont
ancient same-sex marriage license crazy
preach same-sex wedding chapel pitch of
the day since I don't know how he keeps
getting airtime